neben berlin gedachten auch in
zahlreichen anderen städten tausende
menschen der opfer des anschlags in
hanau mahnwachen mit hunderten
teilnehmern gab es unter anderem in köln
duisburg frankfurt
die ermittlungen konzentrieren sich auch
auf die motive des täters und auf die
frage ob er allein gehandelt hat
36 stunden sind vergangen seit der
gewalttat die kerzen sind erloschen die
trauernden haben sich zurückgezogen
nur polizisten sind noch an den tatorten
die spurensuche dauert an
viele der opfer waren kurden getötet an
einem ganz normalen tag ihres lebens
weil sie nicht in das weltbild des
täters passten die politik muss den
kampf gegen rechtsextremismus ganz oben
auf die agenda setzen und jetzt muss
auch endlich mit polizeilichen mitteln
gegen den rechtsextremen vorgegangen
werden neben der forderung nach
politischen konsequenzen steht heute die
frage nach den ursachen war tobias r
krank war seine tat politisch motiviert
klar ist fremdenfeindlichkeit und
verschwörungstheorien spielten eine
entscheidende rolle
psychische labilität fast eine
grundvoraussetzung um in den terror
waren abzugleiten weil sie ja eine eine
lücke brauchen in ihrer in ihrer psyche
in ihrem denken dass dann gefüllt wird
durch terroristische waren ideen das
heißt also da muss schon immer etwas
vorgelegen haben und jetzt zu sagen das
wäre nur aufgrund der psychischen
erkrankung so weit gekommen das verkennt
den kern des problems
und neben der frage nach dem warum steht
die frage hätte die tat verhindert
werden können und damit geht es auch um
waffenbesitz und polizeiliche
überwachung